problem 38 in the drawing below the
figure formed by the squares with sides
that are labeled x y and z is a right
triangle so the figure so it's a right
triangle so they're saying this thing
right here is a right triangle and they
ask us which equation is true for all
values of x y and z so really they're
just trying to see if you remember the
pythagorean theorem by tagorian
pythagorean theorem the pythagorean
theorem and that just tells us that if
we have a right triangle
that the square the sum of the squares
of the two smaller sides so x squared
plus y squared
is going to be equal to the square of
the longest side or the side that's
opposite the right angle or we also call
that the hypotenuse
hypotenuse so that's equal to z squared
that's what the pythagorean theorem
tells us and so if we look down here
only one of those match what i just
wrote down are kind of my restatement of
the pythagorean theorem x squared plus y
squared is equal to z squared and that's
this one right there choice b
next problem
problem 39
39 a clothing company created the
following diagram for a vest so i guess
this is somehow a a vest maybe it's half
of the vest because that doesn't see how
i could put that on me to show the other
side of the vest okay right so this was
half of the vest
half of the vest to show the other side
of the vest the company will reflect the
drawing across the x across the y axis
what will be the coordinates of c after
the reflection so when they say
reflection they mean literally you just
take the image of this and you flip it
over onto the right hand side so i could
draw it out let me draw it in blue
so if i take the reflection
this line right here is at negative one
it's one to the left of the y axis so
when i take its reflection i would draw
it right here one to the right of the
y-axis
when i this line down here
it goes from
it goes from one to the left all the way
to four to the left on this side it's
going to go from one to the right all
the way to four to the right all the way
to four to the right and i could keep
doing it this this
segment right here fe when i flip it
will become this segment
right here
this segment
d e
right here will become
this segment it'll just look something
like this when i go on to that side
and then c
c right here is 2 to the left of the y
axis so c over here will be 2 to the
right of the y axis so it's going to
look something like this so the best is
going to look something like
this and then of course it just dips
down like that so that's the right hand
side of the vest but they want to know
what is the coordinates of c so this is
c and this is the c after the reflection
maybe i could call it c prime and so its
coordinates are
its x coordinate is two right we're two
to the right before we were two to the
left at minus two and its y coordinate
is going to be the same it's going to be
seven
two
seven and so that is choice a
and
let's well i'll i'll do the next video
well let me there's only two problems in
this video so let me go to the next page
and then next page
number 40 what is the area in square
units of trapezoid
qrst
shown below so we need to figure out the
area of this and they actually even give
us a formula they gave us the formula
for this for this trapezoid so they're
calling it as one-half times the height
times the height times base one plus
base two so essentially just to give you
an intuition of where this comes from
you're essentially saying what's the
average width of this trapezoid so you
take one half
times the sum of this guy and that guy
and that gives you the average width and
then you multiply that times the height
so just applying this formula
it is
one half
times my height
my height is eight
times base one let's call this base one
twenty
plus base two
base two is this six right there so i
have one half times eight which is four
times 26
and four times 26 is equal to
104 square units so that's that right
there so they're really just testing
whether you can apply this formula
whether you can recognize what's the
height and what are the two bases
problem 41.
one millimeter is well here they're just
asking you to they're seeing if you
remember your units remember you know
let me write it this way deci
deci is equal to one tenth
centi
is equal to one hundredth
and then milli
milli is equal to
one
one over a thousand so one millimeter is
one thousandth of a meter
one thousandth of a meter they're just
making sure you remember your your
metric prefixes
problem 42
42. in the diagram below hexagon l m n p
q r so l
m n p q r is congruent to hexagon
s t u v
w
x so and when congruent just means all
the sides are equal and all the measures
of their angles are also equal so they
say which side is the same length as m n
so which side is the same length as m n
so this is m mn right there and we want
to know what side is the same length as
that
so let's let me make sure that they're
not trying to confuse us so they start
here they say lmn so they start here l
m
n p q r and then they say s t
u v
w x so they're not confusing us these
points do correspond s corresponds to l
m corresponds to t and so forth and so
on so this segment is going to be
congruent to that segment right there
segment
t u so m n is the same length as t u
so that is choice
b